antes de empezar quiero contarles algo
que pocas veces se platica en los
escenarios creo que pocas veces nos
permitimos ser vulnerables compartir ese
miedo queda de sus nervios
yo contarles que a pesar de que yo me
dedico a esto ya tiempo atrás tengo
varios años
hablando frente a un público cada que me
paro en un escenario y como una vocecita
ahí yo creo que algunos no van a
entender que suena y de repente como hay
aguas te puedes equivocar o cuidado se
te puede olvidar
o en días como hoy que estoy cumpliendo
un sueño pues tal vez no está listo creo
que son voces que escuchamos no importa
que estemos haciendo siempre hay una voz
que dice te puedes equivocar se te puede
olvidar o tal vez no estás listo esto
varias personas me dijeron que nos lo
dijera y ahora que lo pienso si puede
ser una forma medio rara de empezar una
charla creo que es muy incómodo pero
vamos a continuar
esta charla se llama cinco frases que
frenan en seco tus sueños y quiero que
te pongas a imaginar esa persona que a
veces te ha dicho algo que derrumba tu
motivación que de repente te dicen
como que mejoras otra cosa y se te
quitan las ganas o sea esas veces que es
tan fuerte el comentario que se te
quitan las ganas quiero primero como que
empezar conociendo los y ver cómo como
estamos aquí en el público vamos a
levantar la mano con la siguiente
pregunta quién de aquí tiene un sueño no
importa si es conocer un país aprender
un nuevo idioma emprender algún negocio
que creo que la mayoría por algo estamos
aquí y la segunda pregunta es a quien
alguna vez con así con una frase les han
apagado la motivación les han quitado
esos sueños y hoy incluido en eso yo
creo que también a bastantitos creo que
es algo que nos pasa a todos los que
tenemos sueños la primera frase que nos
pueden decir es no eres bueno en lo que
haces o no eres bueno en lo que haces
si quieres toqué el piano tiziano tienes
manos muy chiquitas
si quieres cantar dicen nueva como que
no eres tan afinado tan afinada que no
sé qué quieres dibujar como que tus
dibujos no están muy bien proporcionados
si nos dicen que no yo para esta frase
quiero mostrarte algo en una diapositiva
pero antes de pasar te doy un poco de
contexto
yo soy licenció en mercadotecnia pero me
dedico actualmente a la ilustración creo
la imagen de marcas de eventos de ropa y
actualmente a eso me dedico pero hace
unos 12 años hacia esto
colores muy saturados un superman man
recortado un logotipo que decía ese ere
que podría hacerte señor pero super
ricardo ver en mi mente y este dibujo de
los virus de la portada lady donde
claramente john lennon parece más como
un duende
ringo starr se ve que tuvo una vida muy
de rock star
pues george harrison parece más como
diego verdaguer hay algo raro pero el
que más me llama la atención es paul
mccartney que ni siquiera lo termine o
sea como que en mi mente dije como que
ya la flojera así lo voy a subir
probablemente todas las personas que
vieron eso dijeron hoy dedícate otra
cosa es algo diferente o sea no te
dediques a al diseño al dibujo la
ilustración
año con año me he ido preparando me he
ido tomando cursos
carrera diplomados y hoy en día a eso me
dedico tengo la fortuna de hacer lo que
me gusta y divertirme haciendo esto
entonces cuando alguien te diga o sea no
haciendo esto lo hago mejor verdad
cuando alguien te diga no eres bueno en
lo que haces
dile tal vez ahorita no pero estoy
aprendiendo me voy a preparar para un
día si poder ser el mejor es el diga
mucho con esta otra frase que dice hay
muchas personas mejores que tú y déjame
te digo algo cuando te digan eso tienen
razón
hay muchas personas mejores que tú
muchas personas mejores que yo hay
personas más talentosas
personas con más dinero personas más
preparadas en fin hay infinidad de
personas que están mucho más preparadas
que tú pero sabes que hay una frase de
doctor si el autor de libros como el
grinch
gato y su sombrero mágico el lorax todos
estos libros que son como en rima y que
después se convirtieron en película que
dice aquí está en inglés pero yo te la
comparto en español dice hoy tú eres tú
y eso es más real que la verdad y no hay
nadie vivo o sea no hay nadie ahorita en
el mundo que sea más tú que tú nuestra
creatividad viene de lo que somos de lo
que pensamos de lo que sentimos de lo
que vivimos de con quién nos rodeamos
con nadie es igual a ti nadie es más tú
que tú tal como dice la frase suena raro
pero si lo piensas un poquito más tiene
sentido entonces puede haber unas
personas muchísimas más preparadas con
muchísimo más talento pero qué importa
tú eres tú y nadie se le va a ocurrir lo
mismo que a ti
esta es otra frase que a mí me han dicho
y quiero darte un poquito de idea de mi
vida o por qué nace esta conferencia no
hay una persona muy cercana a mí yo creo
que para este punto que le has estado
poniendo cara a la persona que diste
esas frases lo más probable es que sea
alguien cercano alguien que te entiende
alguien que te conoce alguien que de las
pocas personas que sí te dice algo mal
no te importa su opinión y ella es
cuando más cala no es cuando cuando es
un amigo cuando es una pareja cuando es
un familiar cuando es tu jefe que sabe
pues él conoce mi trabajo porque me dice
esto
imagínatelo o imagínate la a esta
persona en tu mente y cada que yo te doy
una respuesta para estas frases piensa
que se la estás diciendo como para irnos
relajando y ya se lee como con un
poquito más de idea esta es otra frase
nadie te va a dar oportunidades
y te vuelvo a decir tienen razón
así como darte las oportunidades nadie
nadie te va a regalar nada y yo creo que
es algo que vamos a escuchar
constantemente como común denominador en
todas las charlas del día de hoy
todos tuvieron un momento donde
decidieron dar un paso donde decidieron
animarse a hacer lo que querían donde
rompieron con un momento donde todos le
decían que no era posible que no podían
y aún así lo quisieron intentar
entonces nadie te va a dar oportunidades
cuando te digan eso tú puede responder
si tienes razón y yo no estoy esperando
que me den oportunidades
yo estoy creando mis propias
oportunidades o me estoy preparando para
merecer me esas oportunidades
hoy esta frase yo creo que es el miedo
de todos y cuando somos fatalistas es la
que más suena no todo te sale mal y hay
una frase de una serie mexicana de
comedia que está en una plataforma de
streaming probablemente aquí algunos lo
habrán visto algunos no y como les dije
es una comedia entonces la frase viene
como que con tonos de burla y el
personaje que lo dice no es el que se
los puedes tomar más en serio pero tiene
mucho sentido una vez que la escuchas y
dice para decirlo
el camino al éxito está pavimentado por
fracasos walter bazar
y claro que tiene razón todos los que
están en algún lado te pueden contar que
algo les ha salido mal creo que hemos
escuchado ya en repetidas ocasiones el
día de hoy vamos a seguir escuchando lo
que no todo sale bien que se cometen
errores que a lo mejor a veces toma un
camino erróneo y de repente tienes que
corregir así como cuando se te olvida y
el google maps está redireccionando así
a veces con nuestra vida cuando te digan
todo te sale mal les puedes responder
si he cometido errores no sé si se me ha
ido mal pero de cada uno de esos errores
he aprendido de cada uno de esos
momentos donde algo no sale como yo
quería he cambiado he mejorado
he descubierto tal vez que no me gusta
lo que estaba haciendo y eso es en
verdad cuando hay un cambio y eso es en
verdad lo que te está acercando al éxito
y antes de pasar a la última frase
quiero darte como un
una actualización de lo que te había
contado hace unos minutos esta persona
cercana a mí qué
me conoce que sabe dónde me duele y
ahora sí lo dice las personas que es la
pocas de las pocas personas que me
interesan lo que dicen y me dice cosas
como estas que acabamos de ver bueno
después de darme cuenta de que pues
podría ser una relación tóxica que podía
hacer ahí como una persona que no estaba
aportando tanto a mis sueños pues se
habla no se habla se trabaja se comparte
de oye pues yo siento veces sabes que
baja el puntito entonces ya hicimos las
paces ya estamos como que agusto ya ya
sabe que me hace daño yo sé que me hace
daño entonces yo también lo estoy
midiendo hasta cuánto escuchar ese tipo
de frases pero a pesar de que ya hicimos
las paces y ya estamos bien la última
vez que me dijo algo no pasé mucho puede
ser hecho unos no sé nueve minutos que
fue cuando me paré en este escenario y
me dijo te puedes equivocar
se te puede olvidar o tal vez no estás
listo
muchas veces nuestro mayor enemigo con
las personas la persona que pone más
trabas somos nosotros mismos
cuántas veces hemos querido intentar
algo y a lo mejor todas las personas a
nuestro alrededor nos dicen baja tú
puedes pero este miedo de no va
y si lo intento y no me sale bien es que
tú dale inténtalo muchas veces la
persona que nos pone el límite somos
nosotros mismos dónde estarías tú
ahorita si tú y sólo tú fueran las
personas encargadas de decidir si puedes
hacer algo o no
dónde estarías
si solamente tú decides que intentas que
no intentas que puedes que no puedes
dónde estarías o sea ahorita obviamente
aquí porque fue una excelente decisión
venir eso no hay dudas pero en tu vida
en tu trabajo con tu familia en tus
proyectos donde estarías
vamos a pensar eso y te quiero dejar con
esta frase que me gusta
que dice los límites no se piensan se
descubren
qué quiero decir con esto los límites no
se ponen aquí los límites no vienen de
yo creo que no puedo o yo me imaginé que
va a ser tan difícil que no voy a poder
los límites no se inventan se descubren
y cuando se descubren después de
intentar intentar intentar intentar
mientras no hayas descubierto esos
límites hay que luchar y hay que
esforzarnos y hay que hacer todo lo que
queramos y cumplir todos esos sueños o
por lo menos intentarlo
mientras estemos en ese plan no va a
haber ninguna frase que pueda frenar tus
sueños
yo soy ricardo argáiz muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]